it will change everything
deep mind solves 50 year-old grand
challenge
the game has changed deep mind's latest
ai breakthrough achieves historic new
milestone helps solve how diseases
invade cells improve protein folding
prediction
ai breakthrough it also wipes your butt
automatically
it is the newest deep mind
big publication actually it's not a
publication yet
but so what happened and i'm sure you've
heard this
um is that every year
there is this competition of protein
folding prediction so proteins are these
structures that
fold in a given way and we'll go into
that in a bit
but basically every year there is this
competition and
the results of this year's competition
came out
and they looked something like this
namely
every entry here you see is a team
participating
in that competition of protein folding
prediction
and there is one team which is
deepmind's
system alpha fall 2 which completely
dominates all the others to the point
where the problem is now considered to
be solved now
solved in in this case uh simply means
that you're past
a certain number in this in this test
set
and if you're past that certain number
your predictions are
useful enough so that other scientists
can basically
take them and base work on them so
that's what it means for this
protein folding problem to be solved
now we don't have much information on
alpha fold
2 yet other than it's really good
and like a blog post and a bunch of uh
advertisement videos by deepmind they
are writing a paper on it
but today i want to go into this blog
post
um maybe parse out what we can
gather from that blog post and i also
want to go
actually through the alpha fold one
paper so as you can see
uh the performance here increased
drastically with alpha fall
2 but you know guesses are high that the
system is going to be somewhat similar
to alpha fold 1 of which we do have a
paper
so today we'll go into alpha fold 1
we'll go into some speculations of alpha
fall 2.
i can already give you my speculation
its transformers
its attention uh that all of a sudden
made this big jump together with
probably a few other
improvements to the alpha fold one
system
basically transformers continuing to uh
dominate the entire field so
where do we start it's probably best
by the way if this is not a great meme
template
i don't know what is just saying just
saying
um yeah so let's actually start with the
problem
itself uh i i realize if you're here
you're probably a
machine learning person might not know
too much about protein
folding so these things here are
computer representations of
proteins they don't really look that way
but
sort of similar um a protein essentially
is a chain of amino acids
so an amino acid uh where do we have
this
right here amino acids are these what
they're called basic building blocks
of life since the proteins
um proteins are what make
the cell do things so protein are sort
of the workers in the cell they are used
as
signaling molecules receptors
uh they are parts of your muscles
actually the parts that move are
proteins
so they they are all the work doers
whenever something needs to work in a
cell do do mechanical or
work proteins are involved and amino
acids are the building
blocks of proteins so each amino acid
has an
has a given a certain common structure
and there are 21 of them so all the
proteins in the world are simply made
out of chains of these 21 amino
acids and
these chains they are formed in so
there's always this sort of body
that can link up to other bodies of
amino acids
it's very similar if you maybe know how
dna is structured
is a very similar concept except in dna
there are four
different bases here there are 21 amino
acids
and each amino acid is a little bit
different
in each amino acid has like a tail that
hangs off
so the tail can be you know look like
this
or it can look like this like a as with
a side chain
are there is there one where it's like
maybe a cyclic one i'm not sure
maybe it can look out here or it can
have sort of no tail at all
i think that's the case for glycine so
the important part is depending on these
on this tail
the properties the chemical properties
of the amino acids are
different and then what happens next
is really interesting once this amino
acid chain is built in
a in this um so this is the the central
dogma
of modern biology is that you have dna
and dna is translated to
um rna sorry
and then it's translated to so it's red
off
copied to rna which is sort of a dna
clone
and then the rna is translated into the
amino acid chain
and there's always three three pieces of
dna
mapped to one amino acid this is very
it's like a compiler notably the
interesting part is that these
steps right here this compilation steps
are
done by proteins so there are proteins
that do these things so nature in a very
real sense
is its own compiler
so this here you can see as like the
binary and this here is like the source
code
but what happens once you build this
chain of amino acid and
you set it out into the cell because of
these different properties of these
side chains they're also called residues
this chain begins to fold and so
this is if you know a bit of chemistry
you might know that
these are these are sort of atoms that
are linked with covalent bonds in this
case
and it can be that part of this chain
is rather like electrically negatively
charged and here part of this chain
might be like
electrically positively charged in a
given place
over a given other place and it also
depends on the surrounding medium of
course
and that means that in this case for
example these two things
will attract and so if you release this
amino acid chain what you're going to
get
is sort of a bend where now the
the chain sort of bends and these two
this chain right here this tail goes
like here
this tail goes like here i'm sorry if
there is no if there is no
um if there's no i don't even know what
to call it pyrene rings or something
like this
if there isn't an amino acid with that i
apologize but
the point is that these two things
attract and sort of form this shape and
this shape is very
important we know that proteins and
proteins consist
of it can be hundreds thousands tens of
thousands
of these amino acids in a chain the
protein's function is
interestingly largely determined by its
structure
by its 3d structure not necessarily
by the actual amino acid so technically
you can
substitute amino acids for each other so
this amino acid here
can be could be substituted for another
amino acid that maybe
isn't the same but is has the same
properties of its side chain such that
if the structure is still the same the
protein would
perform the same function so that
that is is very special property of
proteins namely their
3d structure largely determines their
function
so for example in this step here when
you read off the rna to the dna
as you know the rna is sorry the dna is
like this double
strand of connected
base pairs and in order to replicate the
dna or to
read it off there is a thermal or let's
call it
there's also this step of dna
replication right where you copy the dna
in mitosis in order to do that
you need to split off the two strands
you need to split it up because you want
to get
like a protein needs to get here to
actually read it off
for that there is a protein a specific
protein that will
insert right here to split up the
dna which is called a helicase and
that really is very important how that
protein
is shaped so the shape needs to be
actually such that
it kind of removes these bonds from
each other so the shape is very very
important for a protein and
conceivably you could build a helicase
from many many different amino acid
sequences as long as it has
the same shape now i think something
like something like fundamental like a
helicase is probably conserved
in the evolutionary tree but i hope you
get the point the shape
is super duper important now the shape
uh isn't just arbitrary there are
so the amino acid chain is called the
primary structure and then
the first thing that happens is that two
very distinct
kind of sub shapes appear so often
repeating shapes these things i think
are called alpha
helix helices or helix this is a helix
and this here is i don't know what's in
english it's probably called a strand or
something like this these are like
long sheets like they i think they're
called beta strands
and these things form these are often
repeated sequences and then the third
the tertiary structure is when the whole
thing
starts to kind of fold on itself and so
on and give itself
the um the final structure
so this is part i guess the rna
polymerase which is
the molecule that reads dna and outputs
rna
and there are many many many proteins
now since the shape is so important
um it is vital that we know of it right
and technically technically this is what
why this problem is 50 years old i guess
they say it's a 50 year old problem i
think
that's due to the fact that 50 years ago
a noble laureate said
the following since a protein is
you know fully determined by its amino
acid chain
and since the you know amino acid chain
determines the
structure that it's going to go because
of these uh kind of chemical properties
it should be possible to read in the
amino acid sequence or reading the dna
sequence
we know what amino acid sequence results
and
output the shape of a protein however
this is an
extremely complicated problem it turned
out to be
um because they're very subtle
interactions
they're not always the same it depends
right like somewhere
out here there could be some amino acid
with like some weird chain
that you know everything folds on itself
all the time
so um at some point these get in contact
and the changes kind of the local
properties here
so this is a very very difficult problem
to solve
and um people have have
sort of tried to do this and now
apparently
deepmind the first system that does this
to
such a satisfaction that it's beneficial
all right now i lost my train
of thought um yeah so
the shape prediction what happened so
far is what you'd have to do is you'd
have to
sort of do this determine this
experimentally
so you'd have to take these proteins and
um
crystallize them and then like shoot
x-rays at them
and then infer the structure you can you
can do that from crystallized proteins
because
i think it's due to crystals are like
very regular
uh accumulations of proteins so if you
look at a snowflake
um that is you if we knew nothing about
the water molecule that it's like
uh h2o if we knew nothing of that
we could just look at a snowflake and
determine this
structure this this these specific
angles here
from the snowflake um we would just look
at the snowflakes and
if someone tells us look that's all the
same material that's all water
uh we could infer what the water
molecule looks like
just by analyzing snowflakes because
they're crystals stuff
and the pretty much the same here is you
build you make
crystals out of these materials you
shoot x-rays at them
and then you sort of reason over the
patterns that come out
this is very very difficult very
expensive
and so to solve this problem
computationally is
super important i will get to this
graphic in a minute this is sort of the
only thing we know
about alpha fold 2 is this graphic right
now
because they have not yet released
the the paper or any descriptions of the
model
as i said but what we'll do is we'll go
into
alpha fold one so this is alpha fold one
and alpha fold one
was participating in the same
competition
two years ago and was already dominant
there
but not yet dominant to the point of
having quote quote-unquote
solved the problem just better than
other
systems so this is the basic
structure of alpha fold one
um so what do you what do you have right
here
let's let's give us ourselves an
overview so the overview
is the following there are two different
stages to this algorithm
stage one is over here and stage two
is over here um maybe it's easiest to
start with stage two so
the output of stage one is this thing
right here
a distance and torsion distribution
prediction
so this this this matrix here that's
kind of tilted on its side i believe
there are
more down here right okay
so what you do right here
is you you take an amino acid sequence
and you line it up right here
you line it up this is the amino acid
sequence it's a bit harder if there's
like a split but let's just say
a protein is um actually there can't be
a split sorry that's in the amino acids
i'm dumb
so a protein is a single chain of
um these amino acids
uh there can be multiple sort of parts
to a bigger protein conglomerate
but there is this chain you line it up
here
and here so now we're building sort of a
pairwise matrix between the
sequence and itself okay and this
pairwise matrix is going to be
a distance matrix so what we are
going to do is we are going to input
some features
about this sequence of amino acids right
that's what we get as an input
and we're going to predict for
any pair right so here we have the the
sequence
and we're going to predict for any pair
how far are they apart
so of course here the answer is always
kind of zero they're zero apart
but you might say you know these two are
five
apart and these two here are seven
apart but these two here are only one
apart so it's reasonable you know that
the final structure
the these two are close together
we don't worry about close together
right now we just worry about
for each two we'll predict how far they
are apart
okay so this is you can view this as you
know
a machine learning problem right you
have an input c you have a sequence
and you simply want to predict the
distance matrix so here you can see that
in fact you can see the top and bottom
one is the predicted and one is the uh
real i don't even remember which one's
which
you can see that this system does a
pretty good job at that there
are minute differences if you really go
look like down here
you can see a bit of a difference uh
over here there is a bit of a difference
but in general this system does
a pretty good job so this is the output
of stage one
is this matrix it's a bunch of other
it's like also the torsion angles and so
on but
the main thing is you predict the
distances between
those two that's what you take
as a input to stage
two so what stage two does is stage two
builds a model of this
molecule and the model is sort of a
differentiable geometrical model
so they say they where is it
this i don't get these nature papers
like they're split into two parts but
then they're
they largely say the same things i am
absolutely confused by them so we're
gonna jump around a fair bit
um they say we parameterize protein
structures by the backbone torsion
angles of all residues
and build a differentiable model of
protein geometry to compute the
coordinates for all residues
and thus the inter-residue distances
so what they do is essentially they
build a computer model
of these amino acids and
these are parameterized by the torsion
angles now the torsion angle is simply
the angle between any two of them so
this would be like a torsion angle of
180 degrees
and then if it folds like this
it would be a torsion angle of 90
degrees and so on
and you need two torsion angles because
you're in 3d
but essentially the torsion angles
determine the structure
of the protein so it's one way of
parameterizing it
so they built a differentiable model
a differentiable model of protein
geometry
okay now the important thing is they
don't do any learning with this
differentiable model the purpose of this
differentiable model is
such that um what you can do now
if you have a differentiable model you
can run
gradient descent so imagine
they pretty much lay it out right here
so they have
the x x is um
x is the output of your differentiable
geometry right of your torsion angles
let's just call it this greek letter phi
psi whatever um
[Music]
if x is the output and now x goes into
your loss function
so x goes into your loss function and
the loss function
simply compares x to the predicted x
okay so the loss function will take in x
and it will compare it to the x that you
predicted
from from this thing here
okay so we start off with a flat chain
maybe actually i think we start off with
some initialization
because they also predict the torsion
angles directly
uh right here they're predicted towards
an angle direction and that's what we
initialize from but let's just say we
initialize from the flat chain
and then because this is differentiable
we do so your your l
your l is x minus
x prime okay and what we do is we derive
the loss
with respect to the angle
uh to the torsion angle okay so what
and we can do this since this is
differentiable so now we know how do we
need to change the angle
which is this thing right here uh in
order to make the loss
smaller right and maybe
it says you nee actually you need to
turn it down right
make the angle smaller and we do that
okay cool
now it's only 90 degrees and then we do
it again and again
and again and you can see that by
changing all the angles
such that this loss is smaller we end up
through steps step step
step we we in our computer model we sort
of
replicate this process that happens in
nature
where what we feed in is
how far any two amino acids should be
apart
and by running gradient descent
just gradient descent on the torsion
angles
we figure out what do the angles need to
be
in order to make this happen okay so
first
we predict all the distances and then we
figure out
how do we need to set the angles such
that
these distances are fulfilled these are
not true distances these are predicted
distances right so everything depends on
how well we can
predict these distances but once we have
them we can sort of
replicate in our computers the process
as it happens
in nature except in nature uh
the the whole folding is dependent on
these all these chemical interactions
and so on
and now we do none of this we simply
let's see
how do we need to fold in order to make
these
distances in our computer model like
these like the distance between this and
this
and this and this any two distances
may agree with the distances that we
have predicted
right here and you can see uh that
over time uh this as you run gradient
descent
this goes up this this tm score goes up
the root mean square distance
goes down between then you of course can
compare it if you have a test set
with stuff that people have already
figured out you can analyze these
metrics
and see that indeed you do get the
correct
folding it's also pretty interesting
that so here in uh blue and red
i believe you have yeah exactly so the
the helix in blue and the strands
in red so in this case you
from if you have this
folded structure or partially folded
structure you can already see
that these sort of substructures emerge
like this
is a helix right as you can see
and then you sort of make this may be a
strand and so on there are ways to
heuristically classify that and
you can see that if you look at
the database right you can see that
this here is a strand these are helixes
and this is a strand and these are heli
this is a strand and so on
and you can see that the model here is
what the model thinks at the beginning
it doesn't get many things correct
though it does some
but then over time it sort of refines
its guesses
until at the end it's pretty much you
know
equal to what the to what the
uh database to what the true sample is
and here is simply
the uh distribution of i guess
confidence about these things and
the the torsion angles right here so
it as you can see this two-step process
is um the key here to do that
now alpha fall 2 conceivably probably
changes this
a little bit but again we're not sure
the step one right here is
a deep learning system so step two is
simply a gradient descent procedure that
you run
at inference time right this at training
you
you can you can just do step one so step
one is
is the machine learning bit
so the goal is to output this
distance this distance tensor
right here and there are more things
than distances as we said there are
torsion angles and so on
but ultimately you want to output this
distance matrix
and how do they do it you can already
see it's a deep neural
network so you want to build a
input data point
let's say of l by l which is sequence
length by sequence length so you want to
collect some features you don't know the
distances yet right
but you can collect some features that
are either
either pairwise features between these
two things right so here
um maybe this is i don't know leucine
and this is what's a different amino
acid
glycine and um
in here you want to put features
maybe it can be features for that
position right maybe leucine here
is at the 100th position in the
in this particular protein and this is
at the 90th
position so you want to put in some
features
that of that that you can derive from a
data set
you can put in correlation statistics in
general between these two amino acids
you can even put in uh just single
features
so you have these tiled l by one
uh features which is um
just features for the sequence itself
not pairwise features but what you do is
you simply
replicate them along along
any given dimension right here you
always put the same feature
this is very common uh in convnets
and you can even do a scalar feature so
there are some scalar features
and what you would do is you would
simply fill an entire plane
with that scalar feature all the same
number
it's just easier to do it like this
because it fits into the
convolutional architecture well
so you want to provide all kinds of
features and the features
they provide are you know plentiful and
a lot of them do introduce some domain
tools domain expertise and so on but
once they have that
they simply take that sort of image with
many many channels and they predict this
image if you want so it's just an image
to image
uh translation problem and they do this
via a convolutional neural network as
you can see there are 220 residual
convolutional blocks now i assume that
most of the viewers of this video
are familiar what convolutional neural
networks are if not i'm
deeply sorry but i will not go into that
but you can see they sort of um
they tile this tensor right here and
they tile it differently
from um from from instance to instance
so they tile it they in the training
procedure they always tile it
differently that's a form of data
augmentation
but ultimately you slide over
this image with this 64 by 64
convnet and you produce the image on the
right
here you can see an inherent weakness of
these approaches
namely that this thing can only ever
look at 64 amino acids
at a time so now that can
that can be the same if you're on the
diagonal
of this let's say let's say this is not
64 by 64 but
three by three right if you're on the
diagonal you would only
consider three amino acids and their
interactions
with each other right any to any
interactions with each other
if you're off the diagonal what you
would consider is maybe these three
amino acids
and these three amino acids and you
would
only consider you consider features for
maybe for those three but
interactions only in between
like the these not interactions actually
within
the same amino acids so your the
thing that you can look at any point in
time is going to be
very limited right and these so these
distances that you
get out here they necessarily cannot
directly depend
on let's say this amino acid right here
you
always have this limited view of your
protein
that's sort of local now people argue
that that's actually enough if you look
at maybe the green connections right
here
in order to establish them uh what's
most important is the vicinity
of these uh of this amino acid and the
immediate vicinity of this amino acid
and of course the interaction between
those two vicinities
but it is quite conceivable that this
green thing down here
being so close will actually sort of
push the two apart
and um sort of do this interaction
which in my understanding would not be
covered by a system like this
and that's where alpha fall 2 i believe
is is one point where it makes the big
gains that it does
now the features that go in here
as i said they are they're quite
plentiful
um one of the more interesting features
is this msa this multiple sequence
alignment
and i believe they're they're up right
here
um yeah sequences so
sorry here they introduce them in recent
years the accuracy of structure
predictions has improved
through the use of evolutionary
covariation data
that are found in sets of related
sequences
sequences that are similar to the target
sequence are found by searching
large datasets of protein sequences
derived from dna sequencing
and aligned to the target sequence to
generate a multiple
sequence alignment correlated changes in
the positions of two amino acid residues
across the
sequences of msa can be used to infer
which residues might be in contact so
what with this i've searched out one of
the papers right here and this is uh
from a paper called
improve contact prediction proteins
using pseudo-likelihoods
to infer pots models the entire basis
here
is that here is your chain of amino acid
that you're considering
and this is you this is the human and
they actually have one
like a very similar um graphic in their
blog post but we'll draw this ourselves
i'll just kind of sort of copy it and
what you do
is you go and look into your database
right this
this is the amino acid sequence and each
amino acid can actually be abbreviated
by
a single letter uh since they're 21 and
luckily the uh the holy alphabet
creators have given us
well 26 so that fits um
so each of these can be done by like s
y c m d and so on
can be then you go look into your
database
and your database is of sort of all of
life
and you go look for similar sequences
and there are tools that you can
very quickly see through databases and
get out
similar sequences to yours and that
those are sequences that are
overlapping in amino acid sequence
right so you could find up in the fish
this is an alpha this is not a fish in
the fish
uh there is a similar sequence right
here in
the i am like this is okay
in the whatever this is this might be
a horsey no this is not a horse
let's make an alligator out of this so
in the alligator raw
does the alligator have um there might
be a sequence and so
you get the point my drawing skills are
uh to be criticized in another video
so you search for all of these similar
sequences just by by amino acid sequence
and from the correlations you can derive
something for example
i've already told you that sometimes you
can substitute
an amino acid uh and the the sort of
function of the protein isn't really
affected and this may be what you can
see right here so in the human
this is maybe a d but or sorry
maybe this here it's a c um but
in the in the let's call this an m
in the fish it's a c2 but you know in
the alligator it's a p
and in the cockroach it's k and so on
um you can see that
maybe if the alignment is good right
this is
sort of from the same protein or from a
protein that does
maybe the same thing in these uh life
forms because life is continuous
often these things are preserved or
slightly modified
um so here there are variations
that happen in life right mutations
variations
and so we can safely
maybe assume that you know a k whether
there's a k
or a p or a c in this particular point
it doesn't really matter the shape
doesn't seem to be too
affected okay that's so that's step one
and now
so this might be this this protein this
amino acid right here you see whether
it's this chain
or whether it's uh this chain
maybe doesn't really matter for the
function of the protein however
if you look at two proteins that are in
contact
what needs to happen so if
my protein here has this chain and the
other protein has
has sort of is in contact that means
there is like a chemical interaction
between the two
okay so now if a mutation happens
if a mutation happens and the protein is
still functioning the same way but the
mutation happened
let's say it's now um
this right here that must mean the shape
is still the same
sort of and that must mean that probably
if one of them changed the other one
probably
changed sort of analogously at the same
time because structure
is preserved function is preserved so
structure is preserved
and since structure is determined by
chemical interactions one of the parts
changed
that means probably the other part has
changed as well so maybe now this is
sort of
this chain right here so what you would
expect to see in the statistics
is that if one changes the other one
changes accordingly so there can be
variations right there can be mutations
but if the mutation happens in one of
them
a corresponding mutation should happen
in the other one as well otherwise the
protein would be non-functional and the
organism would sort of die um not always
but you know this is kind of a
statistics game
and this is what you see here like the
fish
has an s like the human and an h right
here
but the alligator has an f and a w right
here and then in the cockroach you see
the
s and the h again and so on and here
down here you see the
f and the w again and this
is an indication that this the
correlation here is an indication
that these two things might be in
contact
with each other now there have been
systems
for example in this paper right here
that
directly go from these statistics to
contact predictions and so on
alpha fold simply takes in this stuff
as features so this right here all of
this
there can be i think they derive
488 features from this so this goes
down here i think they say it again
as i said this is confused like here
article stops references
article starts again thanks and they
like say
almost the same things it's just a
little bit more detail but it's not
longer
so here they derive 484 features from
this multiple
sequence alignment for each
residue pair right so in our big tensor
right here
right here each dot each thing right
here already now has
400 so
each one of these already has 484
features
and then some more right this is already
this is from the msa
but then more features so they
incorporate lots of features right here
where we at here incorporate lots of
features
in addition we provide the network with
features that explicitly represent gaps
and deletions
um they also represent scalar features
and so on so here you can see they have
scalar features
sequence length features amino acid type
profiles hh blitz profiles these are all
sort of these
comp bio tools these genetic tools
um and so on you also have sequence
length features
uh these are these 484 features and so
on
so these are all akin there are some
positional one of these acts as
positional encodings
and so on so lots of features input
convolutional network output the
distance
matrix and that's that
right so there you have it the inputs
the
distance matrix from the distance matrix
you can run gradient descent
to get the protein structure at
inference time
and they make some pretty cool points
not not only do they compare the
distance matrices but they
here is the not only the
single prediction for the distance but
they of course output a
probability distribution they bin all of
these distances the output of
probability distribution
and you can see that the black line in
these histograms so this is
this is for a particular thing this is
for this this
red line uh this red
row right here it's the extraction so
it's for one of the amino acid
the distribution of probabilities
of distance bins with
each of the other ones so this is number
29 and we look at the distance between
number 29 and
1 2 3 and so on the black line represent
the represents i think eight angstroms
which is generally considered the
barrier for
being in contact or not being in contact
um and here it's colored in
blue if not in contact and in
green if in contact and the
red bar represents the true distance and
you can see this
is pretty accurate so whenever the
network predicts blue
usually the uh red line is
on the right of the black line and if
the network predicts uh no sorry
uh this green and blue is the ground
truth
so whenever it's blue the network's
distribution is usually shifted towards
the right
and whenever it's green the network's
distribution is shifted
towards the left there are some failure
cases as you can see
right here the network predicts a higher
distance
than the um than the
the truth right you can also see what's
pretty interesting is that the most
accurate predictions sort of the uh
highest confidence the smallest
variation in distribution
are around here which is exactly around
so
29 would be in the middle right here and
that's where you find the most accurate
predictions of course since local local
distances are much more easier and then
as you go further away
you get less sure and this is a cool
thing so here you can see
model prediction versus true distance
fits fairly well
but you can also see that here they plot
the
standard deviation of their prediction
and you can see that
the um the
means are very close but
the higher the sort of standard
deviation um
the less sure the model is so there
there seems to be a
there seems to be like a built-in
confidence
metric right um
so you can see the distance error it
makes here
are bigger and also its standard
deviation is bigger at the same time
which means that you can sort of look at
the standard deviation of this
distribution
right here and that is an estimate for
how
sure how confident the model is in its
prediction
and apparently that's something that in
alpha fall 2
the the model relies on
upon very very crucially
so here you these are just on the bottom
you see one of these residual blocks
here more distance matrices they do a
lot of analysis
in this article which is pretty cool so
you can go into it
uh fairly far they also have look at
what the network pays attention to and
it makes a lot of sense like it pays
attention
to kind of these these helices and then
these interactions between the helices
and the parts where it's
in close contact with and so on but now
we want to go into alpha fold two alpha
fold two
now the what we have isn't much
we have this graphic right here um
which is also in the article it's
probably better we go to the blog post
the blog post is like a fluff piece
saying
we they are going to publish a paper
but of course they don't have it yet
because we've just gotten
the results um
yeah they have they have these these
cool these videos were like
ah so good um
as i said i've like there's so many
twitter threads with
i'm not usually up for the hype but this
is the best thing and so on and
everyone's everyone's hyping and
i thought is it really up to me to be
the grumpy one here
um but then i couldn't find anything to
be grumpy about so
uh this is what we what we get um
let's see it's it's deep mind um
i expect them to not fully
maybe release the code maybe they will
but um in alpha fold one
they've released like half the code
which is already pretty cool so there
are open source implementations based on
that
so again nothing to be grumpy about
all right so what can we what can we say
they say a folded a folded protein can
be
thought of as a spatial graph and then
this is kind of a
new word they introduced but ultimately
it's simply
uh this distance matrix that we've seen
before is a representation of that
spatial graph right it's simply
a graph of nodes and the edges say
whether or not they're in contact or
respectively how far they are apart
where the residues are nodes and edges
connect the residues in close
proximity this graph is important for
understanding the physical
interactions within proteins as well as
their evolutionary history
for the latest version of alpha fold
used at casp14 that's this challenge
we created an attention-based neural
network
system trained end-to-end that attempts
to interpret the structure of this graph
while
reasoning over the implicit graph that
it's building
uh i look this it
sound like this this is
fluff maybe i don't know but this here
attention based okay so i'm going to
guess
uh for sure that they've replaced this
convnet
um with in with a transformer style with
an attention
um attention layer or multiple attention
layers
they say it uses evolutionary
evolutionarily related sequences
multiple sequence alignment and the
representation of amino acid residue
pairs
to refine this graph this is um
this is what we've already seen so use
these other sequences
plus like a lot of stats that you can
gather from the data sets
on amino acid pairs in order to develop
this this graph and the graph is
distance uh the distance matrix or
other things we'll see in just a second
they say by iterating this process
the system develops strong predictions
of the underlying
physical structure of the protein and is
able to determine highly accurate
structures in a matter of days
additionally alpha phil can predict
which parts of each predicted protein
structure
are reliable using an internal
confidence measure
again this is something that we've
already sort of seen in alpha fold one
that there is sort of an internal
confidence measure and the
part here is they say by iterating this
process which could mean that
it's no longer just this two stage
approach but it could be an actually
fully cycling approach that sort of goes
back to the neural network
to refine the structure that it's
building with the gradient descent
procedure it's entirely possible so this
is the graphic
of alpha fold two you can see at the
very beginning you have
protein sequence and um
[Music]
at first you have this embed and outer
embed and outer sum
which i'm going to guess this is just
kind of features
for pairs or individual
amino acids this this is
correlation statistics from your data
set it can be
you know chemical properties whatever it
just a bunch of features that you can
attach to each of these amino acids
in the sequence right um
the other path here is this genetic
search and embed
so this is what we've already seen with
the ms same thing i saw
i told you they have the same graphic so
there's human there's fishy
there's rabbit and you simply search for
sequences in your database it could
even be from other humans right uh that
are similar
and from that from those you can also
derive
features so here is where i'm a bit
confused you can see
they build up this again this square
matrix right here i mean this um it
already screamed the tension before
right
so i'm going to guess they no longer
limit themselves to the
maybe maybe to the 64 by 64 maybe
they do something bigger uh maybe they
use local attention who knows but
i'm going to guess they use attention to
um
and these this here is simply given by
an attention
layer of some sort to go into the next
uh to just uh this is basically
i would guess this is a big transformer
right here
the interesting part is that it appears
to interact
um much like much like the original
transformer
maybe encoder decoder here they pass
information around
so this top thing isn't amino acid
sequence to amino acid sequence like to
itself
but it appears to be a matrix that you
build up
between the amino acid sequence and
these sequences you built
so i would guess that they are no longer
let's say happy with simply inputting
the features
of these algorithms that go over these
other sequences
but now they also want to sort of uh
put these features through through steps
of transformations so again i would
guess
this is an attention layer and how can
we interpret this matrix
as you can see this matrix relates
individual amino acids in the sequence
to other species so i would guess that
this square here represents
something like um how important
is this particular location
in the chain which is a purple thingy in
the human
how important is that in
the in the in the chicken or
how related is that to the chicken
at that particular position or as a
whole i don't know
probably deepmind doesn't know like they
probably just chip these features in
here
right and then they just ship it through
transformers
they pass information around i don't
know whether it's just
in this direction and then in this
direction or whether there's like an
arrow
right here conceivably but in any case
it seems like they've replaced what was
a convnet
so no longer friends with confnet new
best friend
is transformer
and then at the end you see what they
get out
is these pairwise distances
again now it's also not really clear
because i would expect maybe an
arrow going like this if they again use
these pairwise distances to predict the
structure
i don't know okay or if that's just a
side output i would guess they still
actually
use the pairwise distances and the
confidence score
again you can um it might be something
very similar that we saw again
being the sort of standard deviation on
the predicted
distances but they could also refine
that
and then the last thing is i don't know
if this iterative process
is uh simply referring to there being
multiple layers of this attention and
passing around so the passing around
will simply be like
um you stack the representations on top
of each other i don't know if this
is the iterative procedure or if there
is actually
like the structure module actually sort
of um
builds the structure and then goes back
and then you consult the neural network
again and then you
build some more of the structure and so
on i
can't tell right now it's quite
conceivable that they they do like
that the search here is not only
gradient descent but is actually
informed
by the neural network so you can sort of
go back and
refine though i don't know there doesn't
seem to be any features
in the neural networks that would
represent
um that would represent
whatever you could read from a partially
built 3d
model so you know the boring guess is
that the part 2
is very is is a lot of the same
but there could also be a substantial
improvements in that part
all right i hope this was um
this was sort of a good overview um
so as i said the paper isn't out yet
if you want to cite this i guess you can
you can refer to the blog post and here
they say
until we've published a paper on this
work please cite high accuracy protein
structure prediction using deep learning
by these people i just want to highlight
um
shout out to to anna who was educated
right here she was an intern
so in a way i'm actually saying that
this is
my discovery and i take full
responsibility for it
you're welcome world shout out to anna
um
very nice job good work good work to all
of these people
and yeah i hope that was
enough uh if i got something horribly
wrong
please tell me in the comments and
share the video out if you liked it
other than that
have fun bye